hey guys how's it going it's Justine
happy Halloween I'm so excited because
today we're gonna be making a graveyard
cake yes you heard that correctly I have
pretty much everything already prepped
because you guys see me make plenty of
cakes you've seen me rule out form so
just imagine and picture that I just did
all of those things right now so for
this fondant I actually just used white
fondant and I rolled in this brown food
coloring and this is we got a nice
little tan dirt so first things we're
gonna ice up this cake and then we're
gonna roll out the fondant and we're
gonna start decorating
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't know why I'm such a
perfectionist when it comes to icing
like literally my like life and house
and everything can be falling apart but
I'm like I've gotta make sure I use the
cake perfect for you I would put this in
the fridge this will chill up and then
we're gonna roll out dude dude dude our
fondant and then we'll continue with
this video I like dusting my workspace
with a little bit of powdered sugar oh
yeah this is a great dirt color look at
that I don't know how to use this oh
this looks like too much work because
this will let you roll out to like a
very even level it's quite a hefty
little a slab of fondant I am exhausted
[Music]
so folks guys get back in there
this works and we have to place it on
top of here and I'm very nervous because
this is a very finely rolled fondant
especially for me because I'm not good
with fondant oh gosh oh my oh my oh my
oh boy oh wow oh wow oh wow okay oh God
you didn't see anything you saw nothing
I really messed up the side are really
bad it's crunch this in like so it
fondant is so cool like this is awesome
I just rolled this out yeah I made a few
mistakes because I don't wanna talk
about let's get this real nice around
these edges looks moderate not my best
work not my worst work you guys have
seen some things here
[Music]
definitely some clean-up on aisle
graveyard here mmm
I cut that one a little bit too much now
I've got some tombstones that we're
working with they're so cute they also
have little bones in them - if there's
an edible marker so you can write on the
tombstones so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna dig up a little grave here so for
the dirt we're gonna using Oreos so I
basically just need real close
we're gonna put some Oreo tops into a
bag so let's open these up and see what
we're working with here cuz I have no
idea this is gonna look great
I'm so excited okay here we go let's
write PI P very original hey now we got
to figure out our placement of where
these are gonna go so we're gonna put
one right here so I'm just gonna cut out
like a little I guess area for it
yeah look at that that looks great and I
like that these can kind of be a little
messy because it's clearly a graveyard
and it's not gonna be like a very neat
place
[Music]
he looks so cool okay put you in there
so now this is where it's gonna get
silly
cuz I got a cutout of Grave this is a
fresh fresh grave look at that oh my god
I love it I love it this is so great so
I have a little bit of icing inside of
here because I'm gonna put the Oreos
over top of it so I want to kind of
stick like it's the dirt mm-hmm
perfect oh my god it looks just like
dirt oh alright in we go another grave
let's smear some smudges of this on here
so that we can get some of the dirt like
look on it to stick from the Oreos yeah
that's great it's a look
yep that's a mess
that's quite a mess Pete everything wow
this looks like a mess I'm gonna dust
this off over the sink oh my god is
everywhere look what I did I dusted it
everywhere oh my little bones
let's get be somewhere who put one
coming up from this brave yeah look at
that oh that looks so great I love it on
the side there where's mine where's mine
your weapons
I'll stick one in here we'll put it
right here yes we will
right now I'm gonna line this whole edge
with some brown probably gonna look like
trash but no promises oh you have not
already messed up
[Music]
happy Halloween may I offer you a
graveyard delight
[Music]
[Applause]
I'll see you in my next video leave me
some comments on what you guys would
like to see me bake next Thanksgiving is
coming up so I'm not really sure I
thought about trying to make a
Thanksgiving meal but that could
potentially be a disaster let me know
what you guys plan on being for
Halloween I'm sure you guys will see my
costume on Instagram if I decide to
dress up in the meantime um don't forget
to subscribe make sure you guys like
this video and I'll see you in the next
one bye bye okay cool great don't care
anymore can you do some slow-mo yeah
[Music]
[Applause]